The peptide therapy includes the following peptides.
So, so the peptide therapy includes the following, includes the following.
The polylyseid is the only peptide in that group. So understand, polylyseid is the peptide. The
emissited is, aren't emissited, that's an herb. IP-6 is IP-6, that's a component to minerals, you know,
certain form in an IP-6 exiled structure.
Blue to thiode is blue to thiode, NAD is precursor to nitric oxide,
nitric oxide stimulator and colloidal silver. So, the treatment in this peptide therapy as far as quality
to peptide therapy is the polylyseid. The other ones are something different.
Again, I personally would not recommend blue to thiode for a cancer patient or NAD for cancer patients.
And the polylyseid is the peptide in the peptide therapy is still a question for me.
But again, that's, you know, that's something you're going to have to make a decision on.